this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman and not
just Hulk and Iron Man are fighting on
the streets this week also mr.
incredible and Batgirl squared off it's
true I know what your sauce and I was it
was just like that it was just like the
Avengers it was a battle royal on
Hollywood Boulevard between mr.
incredible and Batgirl they squared off
there was like The Avengers because then
out of nowhere Freddy Krueger showed up
and Waldo and it was just man I we have
the trailer for that film - it's coming
out - in May here's here's the
characters brawling on Hollywood
Boulevard at the beginning we see mr.
incredible and Batgirl struggling
Chewbacca tries to break it up Batgirl
scratches mr. incredible Waldo and
Freddy Krueger's step in they try to
hold back mr. incredible who gets loose
chases Batgirl throws a punch kicks her
and then flips her onto the sidewalk
bystanders chase them off no characters
out tonight saw the fight which the
videographer says happened around 5:00
p.m. but this guy but what should I call
you shite what do you go by of all time
first of all they're calling the fight
like it's a bit like it's a battle and
then that Chewbacca comes in and then I
see a shot at our Batgirl back and let's
flip that oh and here comes Waldo here
comes Freddy Kreuger and the him Batman
is standing there and she says what
should I call you
he stays true to the character Batman
that is [ __ ] I'm done that Waldo got
into mix because every time I have it
ever fight it's always been like Where's
Waldo Waldo he never steps up
[ __ ] you file it's too late in the show
to file man this is where all the bad
jokes go in the defense
[Music]
you
[Music]